si le raisonneur s'y complaît.
La raison peut-elle forcer le raisonneur à vouloir
moins de cruauté et de gaspillage ?
RNG : Toute seule, la réponse est non,
mais il suffit de peu pour basculer vers le oui.
Deux conditions doivent être remplies :
La première est que les raisonneurs doivent se préoccuper
de leur propre bien-être.
C'est l'un des intérêts qui doit être présent
pour que la raison puisse fonctionner,
il est évidemment présent en chacun de nous.
Nous nous soucions tous passionnément
de notre propre bien-être.
La deuxième condition est que les raisonneurs
fassent partie d'une communauté de raisonneurs
capables d'affecter leur bien-être mutuel,
de dialoguer entre eux,
et de comprendre le raisonnement les uns des autres.
C'est certainement le cas pour notre espèce, qui est
grégaire et loquace,
dotée de l'instinct du langage.
SP : Eh bien, cela me paraît juste en théorie,
mais les choses ont-elles fonctionné dans la pratique ?
En particulier, cela peut-il expliquer le développement historique majeur
dont j'ai parlé il y a environ cinq ans ici à TED ?
À savoir, le fait que nous semblons devenir de plus en plus compatissants.
Il y a des siècles, nos ancêtres brûlaient des chats vivants
en guise de divertissement populaire.
Les chevaliers se faisaient constamment la guerre
en essayant de tuer le plus possible de paysans de l'autre.
Les gouvernements exécutaient des gens pour des raisons frivoles,
comme avoir volé un chou
ou critiqué le jardin royal.
Les exécutions étaient conçues pour être aussi longues
et aussi douloureuses que possible, comme la crucifixion,
l'éventration, le supplice de la roue.
Les gens respectables avaient des esclaves.
Malgré tous nos défauts, nous avons abandonné ces pratiques barbares.
RNG : Pensez-vous que c'est la nature humaine qui a changé ?
SP : Pas exactement. Je pense que nous entretenons des instincts
donnant lieu à des éruptions de violence,
comme la cupidité, le tribalisme, la vengeance, la domination et le sadisme.
Nous avons aussi des instincts qui peuvent nous en éloigner,
comme la maîtrise de soi, l'empathie, le sens de l'équité,
ce qu'Abraham Lincoln appelait « les meilleurs anges de notre nature ».
RNG : Si la nature humaine n'a pas changé,
qu'est-ce qui a revigoré ces « meilleurs anges » ?
SP : Eh bien, entre autres, notre cercle d'empathie s'est élargi.
Il y a des années, nos ancêtres ne ressentaient de compassion
que pour leur famille et pour les habitants de leur village.
Avec le développement de l'alphabétisation et des voyages,
les gens ont commencé à compatir avec des cercles de plus en plus larges,
le clan, la tribu, la nation, la race,
et peut-être, à terme, l'ensemble de l'humanité.
RNG : Les scientifiques rigoureux peuvent-ils
donner autant d'importance à la tendre empathie ?
SP : Oui, c'est ce qu'ils font.
Les neurophysiologistes ont découvert des neurones
qui réagissent aux actions des autres personnes
de la même façon dont ils réagissent aux nôtres.
L'empathie apparaît tôt dans la vie, peut-être avant l'âge d'un an.
Les livres sur l'empathie sont devenus des best-sellers,
comme « La Civilisation Empathique »
et « L'Âge de l'Empathie ».
RNG : Je suis en faveur de l'empathie. Qui ne l'est pas ?
Mais toute seule, c'est un outil peu convaincant
pour être le moteur du progrès moral.
Premièrement, elle est subjective par nature
et s'oriente vers la famille directe, les bébés,
et les animaux mignons et doux.
Côté empathie,
les étrangers moches peuvent aller se faire voir.
Même nos meilleures tentatives pour étendre notre compassion
à ceux qui ne sont pas directement liés à nous
échouent à chaque fois, et cette triste vérité de la nature humaine
a été soulignée par Adam Smith.
AS : « Supposons que le vaste empire
de Chine ait été soudainement avalé par un tremblement de terre,
examinons de quelle manière l'Européen le plus humain
réagirait en recevant la nouvelle de cette affreuse calamité.
J'imagine que d'abord il exprimerait vivement
la douleur que lui cause l'infortune d'un peuple entier,
qu'il ferait quelques réflexions mélancoliques
sur la précarité de la vie humaine,
après avoir exprimé tout ce que ses sentiments humains lui inspirent,
il retournerait à ses affaires ou ses plaisirs
avec autant de facilité et de tranquillité
que si une telle catastrophe n'avait pas eu lieu.
Si on devait lui couper son petit doigt demain,
il n'en dormirait pas de la nuit,
mais pourvu qu'il ne les ait jamais vus, il ronflera d'un sommeil profond
après la destruction d'une centaine de millions de ses frères. »
SP : Si l'empathie ne suffit pas à nous rendre plus humain, quoi d'autre ?
RNG : Vous n'avez pas mentionné ce qui pourrait être
l'un de nos « meilleurs anges » les plus efficaces : la raison.
La raison est musclée.
C'est la raison qui donne l'impulsion pour élargir ce cercle d'empathie.
Chacun des progrès sur le plan humain
que vous avez mentionnés a commencé grâce à des penseurs
qui ont trouvé des raisons pour lesquelles certaines pratiques
étaient indéfendables.
Ils ont démontré que la façon dont les gens traitaient
tel groupe était illogique
vu la manière dont ils avaient exigé d'être traités.
SP : Vous dites donc que la raison
peut faire changer l'avis des gens ?
Ne se cramponnent-ils pas à n'importe quelle conviction
pourvu qu'elle serve leurs intérêts
ou se conforme à la culture dans laquelle ils ont grandi ?
RNG : Voici un fait fascinant à propos de nous :
Les contradictions nous dérangent,
du moins quand nous sommes obligés de nous y confronter,
ce qui est une autre façon de dire que nous sommes sensibles à la raison.
Et si vous regardez l'histoire du progrès moral,
vous pouvez tracer une corrélation directe entre les arguments raisonnés
et les changements dans la façon dont nous pensons réellement.
Il est arrivé très souvent qu'un penseur présente un argument
pour montrer que telle ou telle pratique était indéfendable,
irrationnelle, incompatible avec les valeurs déjà en vigueur.
Que leur essai se répande,
soit traduit en plusieurs langues,
débattu dans les pubs, les cafés et les salons,
et à des dîners,
et influence les leaders, les législateurs,
et l'opinion populaire.
Puis leurs conclusions finissent par être intégrées
au bon sens moral,
effaçant les traces de l'argument initial
qui nous avait fait arriver jusque là.
Peu d'entre nous estiment nécessaires de nous lancer
dans une argumentation philosophique rigoureuse
pour expliquer pourquoi l'esclavage est mauvais,
pareil pour les pendaisons publiques ou le fait de battre les enfants.
À présent, ces choses semblent simplement mauvaises.
Mais ces arguments précis ont dû être formulés à un moment,
ils l'ont été dans les siècles passés.
SP : Vous dites que les gens avaient besoin
d'un argument détaillé pour comprendre
pourquoi c'était un tout petit peu mal
de brûler des hérétiques sur le bûcher ?
RNG : Eh oui. Voici le théologien français
Sébastien Castellion qui explique pourquoi.
SC: « Calvin dit qu'il est sûr d'avoir raison, d'autres groupes religieux aussi.
Qui sera juge ?
Si les choses sont si sûres, pour qui le sont-elles ? Pour Calvin ?
Pourquoi écrit-il autant de livres sur une vérité aussi évidente ?
Compte tenu de l'incertitude, nous ne pouvons définir les hérétiques
que comme ceux avec qui nous ne sommes pas d'accord.
Du coup, si nous décidons de les tuer,
la conséquence logique sera une guerre d'extermination,
car chacun est sûr d'avoir raison. »
SP : Pareil pour les punitions horribles comme le supplice de la roue ?
RNG : L'interdiction, dans notre constitution,
des châtiments cruels et inhabituels
a été faite en réponse à une brochure distribuée en 1764
par le juriste italien Cesare Beccaria.
CB: « À mesure que les supplices deviennent plus cruels,
l'âme, semblable aux fluides
qui se mettent toujours au niveau des objets
qui les entourent, s'endurcit,
après cent ans de punitions cruelles,
le supplice de la roue ne provoque pas plus de peur
que l'emprisonnement ne l'avait fait auparavant.
Pour qu'une punition atteigne son objectif,
il suffit que le mal qu'elle cause
surpasse le bien que le coupable a retiré du crime,
ce calcul doit prendre en compte la certitude de la sanction
et la perte du bénéfice que le crime devait produire.
Toute sévérité au-delà de ces limites devient superflue, donc tyrannique. »
SP : Pourtant, les mouvements pacifistes ont été déclenchés
par des manifestations gigantesques,
par les mélodies accrocheuses des chanteurs de folk
et les photographies déchirantes qui montraient le coût humain de la guerre.
RNG : C'est certain, mais les mouvements pacifistes modernes
remontent à une longue chaîne de penseurs
qui ont fait valoir les raisons pour lesquelles nous devons mobiliser
nos émotions contre la guerre,
comme le père de la modernité, Érasme.
Érasme : « Les avantages qui découlent de la paix se diffusent de tous côtés,
bénéficient à un grand nombre de personnes,
tandis que pour la guerre, si elle se finit bien pour l'un des partis,
l'avantage qui en découle bénéficie à quelques personnes indignes d'en profiter.
Un homme n'est en sécurité que parce qu'un autre a été détruit.
Le trophée de l'un provient du pillage de la propriété d'un autre.
Ce qui donne lieu à des réjouissances d'un côté
est cause de deuil de l'autre.
Tout ce qui est regrettable dans la guerre est extrêmement regrettable,
à l'inverse, tout ce qui est considéré comme de la bonne fortune,
est en fait une bonne fortune sauvage et cruelle,
un bonheur mesquin dérivant son existence du malheur d'un autre.
SP : Tout le monde sait que le mouvement
pour l'abolition de l'esclavage était fondé sur la foi et les émotions.
C'était un mouvement mené par les Quakers,
il ne devint populaire que quand le roman de Harriet Beecher Stowe
« La case de l'Oncle Tom » devint un best-seller.
RNG : Mais le mouvement a été lancé un siècle auparavant.
John Locke s'est rebellé contre tous les millénaires pendant lesquels
cette pratique avait été considérée comme parfaitement naturelle.
Il a fait valoir qu'elle était incompatible
avec les principes de gouvernement rationnel.
John Locke : « La liberté des hommes soumis à un gouvernement
a pour la conduite de vie une certaine Règle
commune à tout ceux de cette société,
prescrite par le pouvoir législatif qui y a été formé,
de sorte qu'ils puissent suivre et satisfaire leur volonté en toutes choses
auxquelles cette Règle ne s'oppose pas,
et qu'ils ne soient point sujets à la volonté,
inconstante, incertaine, inconnue, arbitraire d'aucun autre homme,
comme la liberté de la Nature consiste à n'être soumise à aucune autre loi
qu'à celle de la Nature. »
SP : Ces mots me disent quelque chose. Où les ai-je déjà lus ? Ah oui.
Mary Astell : « Si la souveraineté absolue n'est pas nécessaire
dans l'État, pourquoi le serait-elle dans la famille ?
Si elle l'est dans la famille, pourquoi pas dans l'État
puisqu'on ne peut arguer d'une raison pour l'un
qui ne puisse s'appliquer avec encore plus de force pour l'autre ?
Si tous les hommes naissent libres,
comment se fait-il que toutes les femmes naissent esclaves,
comme c'est le cas si l'on considère qu'être soumises
à la volonté inconstante, incertaine
imprévisible et arbitraire des hommes
est la nature même de l'esclavage ? »
RNG : Ce genre de cooptation,
c'est exactement ce que fait la raison.
Un mouvement pour l'élargissement des Droits de l'Homme
en inspire un autre car leur logique est la même,
une fois que cela est bien ancré dans toutes les têtes,
il devient de plus en plus gênant
d'ignorer les problèmes d'incohérence que cela cause.
Dans les années 1960, le mouvement des droits civiques
a inspiré les mouvements pour les droits des femmes,
les droits des enfants, les droits des homosexuels, et même ceux des animaux.
Deux siècles entiers auparavant,
le penseur des Lumières Jeremy Bentham
avait exposé le caractère indéfendable
de pratiques alors habituelles, telles que
la cruauté envers les animaux.
JB: « La question n'est pas : peuvent-ils raisonner ?
ni : peuvent-ils parler ? mais : peuvent-ils souffrir ? »
RNG : La persécution des homosexuels.
JB : « Pour ce qui est d'un mal causé directement,
il est évident que [la pédérastie] ne produit de douleur chez personne.
Au contraire, elle produit du plaisir.
Les partenaires sont tous deux consentants.
Si l'un des deux n'y consent pas, c'est là un crime
totalement différent quant à la nature de ses effets :
c'est une atteinte à la personne. C'est une sorte de viol.
Mis à part celui de la douleur,
le danger, si danger il y a, serait en grande partie
celui de la contagion de l'exemple.
Mais quelle est-elle ?
Inciter autrui à se livrer aux mêmes pratiques ;
Or cette pratique ne produit quelque douleur que ce soit
chez personne. »
SP : Pourtant, dans tous ces cas, il a fallu au moins un siècle
pour que les arguments de ces grands penseurs
soient réinjectés dans la société et influencent l'ensemble de la population.
Cela fait un peu réfléchir à notre propre époque.
Nous livrons-nous à des pratiques
contre lesquelles il existe des arguments que tout le monde est capable de voir
mais que nous continuons malgré tout à pratiquer ?
RNG : Quand nos petits-enfants regarderont en arrière,
seront-ils aussi consternés par certaines de nos pratiques
que nous le sommes par l'esclavage, l'autodafé d'hérétiques,
la violence conjugale et l'homophobie pratiqués par nos ancêtres ?
SP : Je suis sûr que tout le monde ici pourrait trouver au moins un exemple.
RNG : J'opte pour le mauvais traitement des animaux dans les élevages industriels.
SP : L'emprisonnement des délinquants toxicomanes non violents
et la tolérance des viols dans les prisons de notre pays.
RNG : Lésiner sur les dons aux associations humanitaires qui sauvent des vies
dans les pays en voie de développement.
SP : La possession d'armes nucléaires.
RNG : Le recours à la religion pour justifier
ce qui est injustifiable autrement,
comme l'interdiction de la contraception.
SP : Pourquoi pas la religion en général ?
RNG : Je ne me fais pas d'illusions.
SP: Je suis maintenant convaincu que la raison est un « meilleur ange »
qui mérite d'être reconnue à sa juste valeur
pour le progrès moral que notre espèce a connu,
c'est la raison qui est notre plus grand espoir
de continuer notre progrès moral dans le futur.
RNG : Et si, mes amis,
vous détectez une faille dans cet argument,
rappelez-vous juste que vous dépendrez de la raison
pour la montrer.
Merci. SP : Merci.
(Applaudissements)